casual Friday there is no such thing as
a casual Friday
[Music]
honestly casual Friday
is a myth like that Loch Ness monster or
free lunch or the city of Bielefeld look
it up it just doesn't exist why would
you lower your sartorial standards on a
Friday why not on a Wednesday let's do
weirder Wednesday say it's a conspiracy
against good taste casual is for the
home if you're a man over 35 and you're
watching this video you probably
understood a long time ago you look your
very best in a well-cut suit and a time
Y serious successful companies force
this nonsense on their employees is
beyond me no question appears more often
under my videos than this what am I
gonna wear on a casual Friday one guy
wrote to me from Mexico and said in his
company he's not even allowed to wear a
suit on a Friday what has the world come
to but I hear you so if you must go
casual here's what you don't do do not
ever wear anything you'd wear at the
beach or to the gym no trainers or
sneakers either ever jeans if permitted
by your stupid company only dark denim
will do no prestressed faded denim no
holes no patches otherwise chinos off
white or beige in the summer or in
hotter climates seersucker in blue in
colder climates gray flannel is the
classiest option speaking of classy a
turtleneck jumper there's always a good
casual look it goes perfectly with your
trusted navy blazer or PI grey one but
keep it simple and if you're feeling
really casual
maybe a button-down collar and do wear a
tie the midgets live one Loosli time the
other members of the dress-code
brotherhood will appreciate it as a sign
of your civil disobedience against the
tyranny of bad taste that is casual
Friday
[Music]